hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video guys
i'm here to make a big update on what is
happening on spy triple to the global
market we have the interest rate that
decision coming next week uh we had a
bad
day two days ago and yesterday as well
so let's see what can happen next let's
get into it
[Music]
alright guys so like i said i'm going to
go through sp y triple q quickly gonna
have a look at the u.s 10 year
yield which is giving us information
about inflation i'm gonna give you my
view as usual different scenarios and
i'm gonna discuss as well how the
ukraine russia war is impacting what can
happen next week you regarding the fed
decision about the raids so
first spy daily timeframe here we are
guys you know those drawings guys this
chart i've been doing that for two three
months here on youtube on my discord of
course i'm talking
every day every two days about that so
here we are the breakup guys i was there
to tell you that we are breaking out and
that we go over and i told you as well
that we would probably have an abc
because corrections often happen in
three waves abc okay so
a complete b
was full of bull traps we avoided them
and now we're in the c wave so the
question we're having is is the c wave
complete can we go lower if yes where
and what level do we need to trade above
so that both stay back control
if any
so let's answer all these questions
first c waves usually develop in five
waves just like a waves one two three
four five b waves developing three waves
abc and
c waves five waves one two three four
five right not always of course but most
of the time it's the way things happen
because
those
a and c wave waves are the one that are
in the direction of the trend which is
bearish in abc corrections and whenever
you're in the direction of the trend
usually you know you have some extension
that's why you usually have five waves
not only three so here we can count the
waves it's not perfect science of course
guess this is earlier to a theory but
it's helping a lot so one
two
okay no doubt about those two
three no doubt
four no doubt and we are in the fifth
all right so it's not working all the
time but if it is the case here it means
uh we need to make a new low so
to me this fixed wave is not complete
so i know that the pre-market right now
uh i'm doing this video at
three hours before the pre-market u.s s
p futures are trading two percent higher
so we are going to open around here all
right so around 425 okay i think we're
gonna get sold at the open if we happen
here because we are bearish guys we have
some information like this big volume
okay those two red days guys are not
looking like the end of a wave that is
usually happening on lower volume now
here the low volume was in the b wave so
everything looks big here
i don't have here many examples but at
the end of a wave usually you have low
volumes i mean
not increasing volume so whenever the
volume is increasing it's rather looking
like around the middle of
something so here i think we're in the
middle of the fifth wave of the sea wave
so let's see let's see if this is
happening if we get sold today 415 is
still support but we it has been tested
yesterday it hold if it's tested again
today i don't think it might hold the
stem it can break and if it breaks we
would go to 407 all right why 407
because it's a support level that is
coming from here it's not perfect i
would rather pull it i try to match as
many levels
here i have three candles consolidation
here i have a one here one so maybe 400
405 something like that it's of course
an area it's not very press precise so
yeah this is my preferred scenario once
again because of the volume because of
elliott theory that is telling me that
the c wave doesn't look complete and
yeah that's pretty much it now let's
check the alternative scenario it's not
i don't have a strong confidence index
for the scenario which says 60 40 for
the bearish case but we still have 40
chance that the sea wave is complete and
that it was a trunk truncated sea wave
which happens of course
in this case if we happen here and we
manage to
close above 427
okay which is the clear resistance that
we're having right now okay why because
we have same thing as one two three four
five six
recent reactions and look in the past
uh four
like older reactions so this is this was
a clear support it is now a clear
resistance so my take is that we go
there today and we get rejected but
let's see if we close above that it
would be a first
good sign that things are going better
okay because it would be a clear victory
of bulls especially if it's happening on
increasing green volume all right if you
have a green day with increasing volume
this would be a very good sign so let's
hope for that but let's be prepared for
everything then if we manage to close
here it's not over guys okay it's not
going to be over until we at least break
out from this pattern right because as
you can see guys here we have some good
signs let's be honest we have a bullish
regular bullish divergence okay so i'm
not gonna explain exactly what it is but
it's just you can see the momentum is
making higher lows so the momentum is
going up when the price action is going
lower which means that bears are out of
steam they're not able to push the
momentum lower
so it's
it's a bullish configuration but as long
as you don't have a breakout in um
outside of the pattern where you have
those this divergence divergence so here
divergence is coming from this
two lows so you just check what is the
trend and that is looking
the closer to this pattern and it's
definitely this one it's not a perfect
trend line i have one two three and not
even four reactions so the strain line
is not perfect maybe i should do it like
that
i'm not sure i have some noise here but
we are far from it okay so first we
would need to to break out above that
level okay so around 435 so first we
need to close above
427 then 435 and we could still have a
fake out here because once again this
trend line is not clear so to me to be
really looking bullish we need to close
above the 200-day moving average and
this trend line that is the real
resistance that we're having right now
because we have some sense same thing as
just some recent reactions a high here
two recent lows here
uh consideration here and the 200 day
moving average just above that level so
this level makes a lot of sense to me i
could make it slightly higher
so let's say 445 so we are far from that
but i'm just giving you the scenario for
the coming week maybe i'm not going to
do in your life in the this week of
course on this code i can make whenever
you ask me to do guys but here i'm
giving you a weekly scenario so if we
close next week above this level
uh it would of course be very very
bullish this would be probably
uh the guarantee that bulls won the
battle would probably take some time
afterwards but every dip here would be a
very good buying opportunity okay
so this is what i'm seeing guys on this
market now let me quickly discuss what
is happening um so next week we we have
so first tomorrow what do we have we
have the inflation so very important
uh the inflation is going to impact the
10-year yield all right guys because
it's a long-term yield so whenever you
have inflation the u.s 10-year yield is
going higher and it can work as well the
other way around sometimes it's like a
leading indicator so if you see this
going higher
i mean
it's me it means that traders are
betting on inflation and usually
you know they're right if everybody's
betting that inflation is here it's
because you know they have enough data
to think so and if inflation is here you
guys know that we need to increase the
rates faster which is not good for the
market so i'm monitoring this
this is
a typical breakout situation guys we
have a trendline since october 2018 one
two
this was a little bit messy but many
reactions here breakouts
usually as usual guys i'm explaining
that in my course by the way you get
rejected on the first recent high
then we usually uh pull back so we
didn't pull back very deep here but we
had some support as you can see created
by those two highs so we went to the
support so the pullback is validated to
me and usually then we move higher all
right guys and if we do that it would
not be looking good for the market
because it means that we would need to
increase the rates faster now let me
quickly explain the situation between
the war between russia and ukraine is
actually creating a double effect so
we're gonna have the rate the fed rate
decision coming next week and
last week jerome powell in his testimony
said that there is a double impact of
this war first we can see that very
clearly there is uh the community prices
going higher which is creating inflation
which
means that we should increase the rates
quicker faster but in the same time this
war is um is impacting the growth the
global growth because of course a war is
not good for business
so if it's impacting the growth more
that is that it is impacting inflation
we would need to keep the rates lower
than expected all right so the truth
is that it's a very difficult decision
to take i think it's hard to predict
from now what the fed is going to say
next week i don't have a view on that i
think that the inflation issue is maybe
something that we need to handle so i
don't think they're going to slow the
pace but i mean i don't want to take to
say too much about that i don't know
let's be honest
so
let's see what they're gonna say but
this decision would be very uh important
for the market and once again if they
think that it's not gonna impact the
growth that much and that the inflation
is here then they're going to maybe
raise i mean the inflation is going to
be here even more because this is what
is happening you guys can see the oil is
at 125 right now crude oil uh the copper
is higher the wheat is higher
gold is higher i mean everything is more
expensive so we're gonna fill this on
the price of everything sooner or later
so i think that we're not gonna have
very good news coming from that to be
honest but that that's not a strong view
i prefer to wait and see but this is
going to be very important it's going to
happen here guys on the 16th of march
fed rate decision 16th of march and then
the fed press conference that's going to
be very important as well guys so we
have a lot of data coming guys very soon
i mean tomorrow and this week so it's
gonna be very important to see how the
market reacts to that okay now let me
give you my levels on triple two i'm not
to do the same in analysis it's the same
thing guys increasing volume as you can
see on the red day we didn't complete
the fifth wave of the sea wave uh the
level is here 307 so i think we might go
there guys and the 427 level that is
here that is the first level we need to
trade above is at 340 so 340 we're
probably gonna get rejected if we are
not rejected we might go to 350 push
higher then get rejected and if we go
above 350 it would probably looking good
to 370 and 370 is the level we really
need to trade above for at least one
week to be bullish again so guys we're
far from that for now so that's it for
me i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys